hey guys welcome back to Bobby Shekar
today's video mostly consists of me
working on these two o'clock salaries
which are going to be placed on top of
the left hill on top of this hill over
here which is also the highest point of
the coaster so these are more or less
going to be the big green ease of the
coaster the most sort of prominent and
visible parts of the scenery from pretty
much all angles and that's why I do
wanna put quite some effort into making
these look exactly the way I want to and
I'll probably still work on these things
a lot more in the future maybe even do
that off-screen which I'll talk a little
bit more about in the future but yeah
these are basically just going to be too
quite simple not too big and not too
crazy clock towers just quite some
simple towers but I did want to get the
look of these towers completely right
because they are so important to how the
coaster looks in general and sort of
like at the end of the lift Hill here
and the start of the rest of the ride
basically and as for the design of them
this is something that I also want to
get back to later in this video as well
but they are mostly just very simple
clock towers where I just kind of
experimented with the pieces that we
have at the moment this one is gonna be
closed and there won't be like a bell
hanging in the middle of it but I just
wanted to have this sort of more
inclined walls over here which will
actually work with the top of the spire
of the building itself which you'll see
in a bit because I wanted to make an
onion dome for this building which I did
take quite a bit of effort but if you
don't know what I'm talking about in any
case an onion dome is a spire which is
shaped like an onion it's very shocking
I know
and well it's not very Victorian and I
really wanted to try to go for as many
Victorian things as I could this is just
something that sort of been on my list
to try in this game for a really long
time because I really like the look of
them they are more common on especially
Catholic churches in like the Alpine
area so in Germany in Austria
places like that you obviously see them
a lot in Russia as well so they're not
entirely the sort of Victorian kind of
thing that I'm looking for but I just
like the shape in general and I figured
it would work quite alright on this
tower and especially with that shape in
house going on underneath this with the
little sort of more narrow part of the
walls underneath this part where the
bells are going to be and yeah that's
basically the simple design for this
coaster in general it was just kind of
tough to get the spires exactly the way
I wanted to I wanted to use this piece
because it's really small and it really
allows you to get the exact shape that
you want to and I'm really happy
actually with how it turned out to like
give you that freedom especially with
the curves and stuff that a an onion
world dome has and it also has that sort
of brassy texture to it
I knew bonnets or fantasize that this
would have a complete brassy look to it
which it doesn't entirely look like
cross obviously since it is just a
wooden little detail that I tried to use
here to make the Tower happen but at
least it sort of looks like the same
color and that's the general idea behind
the look of the Tower and I figured for
quite a while I could maybe stick
something else on top of it because at
the moment it is a bit empty but that's
something that I might always return to
in the future
I've tried the golden like fries for
quite a few times or like the golden
statue sculpture thing but that didn't
quite work out because texture reasons
so that is probably I'm gonna happen to
get these sort of brassy colour onto the
new Tower so this is probably gonna be
the final look of the spire itself but I
might change what's underneath it moving
on to the second bell tower which is
gonna be the high tower I just wanted to
get some asymmetry going here and also
going to be the tower with the like more
open exposed and obvious Bell in the
middle of it and it's also going to have
a really pointy much more Victorian as
expire on top of it and for the rest of
the design it's more or less just a
variation on the idea that I had with
the other Tower just with some slightly
different colors slightly different
details and to create it slightly
different look overall but it's quite a
similar tower to just kind of give them
that sense that they belong together now
what I wanted to talk about what's
probably gonna take quite a while and
you'll see in a second is the very idea
of steampunk behind these two towers
because I might change these quite a bit
in the future and tweak them a lot not
just because they are so important for
the look of the coaster in general but
also because I'm still not entirely sure
about the way that these things are
supposed to be I think a good way to
segue into this is actually a comment
that I received very well not too long
ago actually which was about this
awesome song called glue some gears on
it and call it steel Punk there we go
which was about the fact and this is
also a running gag that used to be told
a lot in the roller coaster Queen three
community a few years ago which is that
people sometimes just slap gears onto
something and call it steampunk or
specifically in roller-coaster country
it would be the idea that you could make
anything and just add a whole lot of
pipes and gears and it would be
steampunk and the issue with that is
that well it's not entirely true because
one of the main sort of ideas behind it
and the issue with that is or at least
what I think from my point of view even
though I'm not too big into steampunk
steampunk isn't really a decoration it's
a design in general and you kind of need
to carry especially if you're going for
that classic steampunk atmosphere some
Victorian style of fashion or
architecture into whenever you're making
steampunk rather than just slapping
gears onto it like there's much more
like deeper design behind it and also it
kind of needs to be functional which is
something that I definitely want to get
back at here because some of the things
I've made are just not functional and I
just more or less did because it looked
good but I might want to get back in
that at some point in the future but
yeah that's the basic premise it kind of
doesn't really make sense to slap gears
onto something where they're not where
they don't really belong because you're
not really making any kind of machinery
or anything useful in that case and I
think I can kind of add to that that I
think just adding lots of detail to
something is not even a really good
thing I think it should just be avoided
because anyone can just add
detail to something and it doesn't
really mean you're necessarily skilled
at something and also it can't just
drown you in detail and if you don't
leave some areas on detail you don't
really notice the detail parts that you
do want to come out and sort of jump at
the viewer then you don't really notice
them as much and it just becomes this
mess of all sorts of things that you
have to look at at the same time which
well I do appreciate it if people talk
about my rights in that kind of way it's
definitely what I am trying to avoid in
a sense that an overall sort of look to
something is much more important than
how many details it has and how much
effort was put into it and coming back
to that while I'm just working on the
tower a little bit which will be quite a
point aspire as you can see I may want
to delete the gears or at least move
them at some point in the future to at
least give them some sort of purpose
because that's my main issue in this
case I mean obviously I do know be
somewhat flexible with this it is still
at the employed after all and I also
think the most important thing is just
to make things look good that should
probably just be the more well most
important criterion to look at so as
long as the gears look good I figure I
should go with them but not having any
function also kind of makes them look
weird so I'll probably end up in the
future
putting the gears onto the other Tower
and just having windows in this tower
and then put a clock over the top part
of that other Tower maybe add some pipe
lines here and there to cool the entire
thing down and make a new steampunk
powered clock tower something along the
lines of that but it's just something
that I want to keep in mind and
something that I to Anna address a bit
over here because I'm not the biggest
into steampunk person but I am very open
for feedback and criticism firm anyone
in the comment section as well
especially the people are into steampunk
quite happily and have suggestions so if
you do have some ideas or things that I
should change because I totally broke
the rules
I'm always open for feedback and
criticism
anyway moving on for a little bit this
is going to be the final more-or-less
look of the towers barring the fact that
I might move the gears a bit and shuffle
them alongside certain places of the
building but this will be the more or
less the basic build up of the tower
they're quite narrow really an important
vertical accents to at least emphasize
the height of the coaster bit because
this is quite a short coaster actually
I'm trying to make this coaster look as
tall as I can without actually making it
look to it without actually making it
tall at all because it is still a family
coaster it's not really that high or
that big but the tower should help to
make this look a little bit more
intimidating and far away from the pots
and on the other hand because these
towers are placed on this hill over here
it does make them look a bit taller than
they really are as well and moving on I
really wanted to make some gears because
I had an idea on how to make them I
still have no idea how to use these
things so I might actually move these
things to someplace else where in the
coaster if I find a good use for them
but I just wanted to make some gears
because I just well yeah I have I wanted
to do it basically and I'm quite happy
with how they turn out though then again
these are more or less useless gears
that don't really have a use over here
so I might want to move them to where in
the future I want to have a chimney
around this part of the park and see if
I can turn that into some sort of
machinery
speaking of which by the way I said part
of the park but I kind of want to clear
up some confusion there this is going to
be just one ride so I won't really add
anything to this this just gonna be one
standalone ride it's inspired by Disney
in the sense that I think it could kind
of figure it could kind of fit into a
Disney park or a similar heavily themed
Park as like a single themed area on its
own and that's also what it what it'll
be most likely made into so it'll be
very sort of standalone section of one
park that you could imagine would fit
into another park like a piece of a
puzzle in Philly but it's not going to
really have
anything else around it's just this one
second because I kind of got some other
things to do as well and some other
plans that I might wanted to try in the
future as well which and I think I've
ever talked about this but I've had the
longtime plan to make a fantasy dueling
flying fantasy dueling inverted vnm
coaster there we go and that is
something I still want to try I might
even try it on some floating islands
still not entirely sure it's not the
most creative idea ever but yeah that is
awfully off-topic I just wanted to have
like a little wall over here just to get
some sort of building ish detail around
this part of the ride I don't add
buildings and well yeah scenery like
machinery around the entire ride much of
the ride will actually just be rock work
and some simple dark not too overgrown
foliage but I'm gonna have some parts
with quite some heavy and dense
buildings and I definitely wanted to
have it around these sides of the towers
do not make the towers look so long and
just have a build up of buildings around
it though again I'm not really sure
exactly what I will do with this part
though there are some ideas that I do
have that I might want to get into
though most importantly I really just
want to try to make a clock because that
really just seemed like a really cool
idea to try and a good way to get some
details and without having to resort to
gears because honestly I've I don't
really see any other ways to easily get
like Victorian elements in or steampunk
elements definitely when it comes to
Victorian scenery there is practically
nothing in the game so while you can
like make something that sort of
resembles it and kind of looks like it
you can't get the exact details of it
right in any sort of way and the same
kind of goes for the machinery that I
was hoping to have and especially now
that debug with which you can rotate
walls is taken out of the game there are
barely any ways to get to that kind of
thing though I do like how that little
brass pipe turn out so I might bring
back some brass pipes here in there for
like
cooling of machinery and stuff like that
in the future I mean on the topic of
scenery one of the things that I do want
to think about and I think n7 on
Shanghai's want worded this really well
I don't really remember what exactly he
said though which is probably really
stupid considering I'm trying to praise
him for it but what I kind of talked
about is that in planet coaster you
don't really make building so much as
you just kind of at the moment lump
different pieces together to make one
big mess that kind of looks like what
you're supposed to make but in the end
if you break it down like if you remove
a certain window if you remove a certain
wall here and there you just find all of
these ugly pieces that stick out from
the details that you try to lump
together to make certain things and this
can make things a little bit messy and
unorganized and not looking so clean
which I'm trying to avoid here and also
it is pretty much the cause for the
enormous lag I've gotten quite a few
questions about why my Park like so bad
and it's not necessarily because it's so
big but just because I've used so many
different details of which you only see
like a very small part like some details
sticking out of walls where 90% of the
object itself is hidden within the walls
and you don't see it but all of those
things are still getting rendered and
that makes the game slow as hell and
even though we did have a awesome
optimization updates and the game
actually runs very well for an alpha
game so far it's not exactly the best
thing to have especially on my poor i5
which can take that much of that kind of
stuff so I do now not go too much into
ridiculous detail and rather just try to
compose it's sort of general area and
look to the coaster that I want without
having to go too much into unnecessary
detail basically so yeah that's just
something I want to do as well as trying
to get a purpose into the stuff that I
build a bit more because without purpose
as we both know it wouldn't exist and
this is something I always do but
especially in this case I feel I don't
really make buildings to make them look
good in general sort of looking from
every angle to make sure that they're
exactly the way I've
- I rarely ever do that actually if at
all usually I just sort of pick a few
angles which you're gonna see them from
and which I want you to see them from
which in this case are really just well
yeah the pure paths that lead toward
this mainly this part of the bridge
which you see over here the other side
of the path and as you enter the lift
hill from the coaster itself are sort of
like three angles that I tried to make
the buildings and the overall structure
of this hill from but not really looking
from any other sort of perspectives so
it probably looks really bad from the
other perspectives but I usually find
it's really helpful to just try to make
things from like a certain perspective
and build the area around that as well
to make sure it kind of looks the way
you intended it to and you can't really
see it in any other way and any other
way would really kind of look almost
backstage ish to not even look at it so
much as a building but more as a part of
just scenery as they car and that's
supposed to be just looked at from like
a certain angle and in a certain way and
sort of framed inside the general
environment and surroundings in a
certain way that you're looking for
which I find it's kind of interesting
because you know just like different
people have different approaches to
making stuff even though it's just
playing a video game but that's more or
less the way that I like to approach it
anyway moving on to a new section here
and this is actually one section that
I'm actually happy you have a bow okay
hmm this is actually one section which I
am actually really happy with how it
turned out and I didn't really expect
that beforehand basically it's going to
be the engine of the little which might
seem a bit strange but I figured I
wanted to turn the left sail into some
machinery because that's just a really
good excuse or purpose I should probably
say and this in this case is especially
inspired by the engines of cable cars
like the one in San Francisco that kind
of stuff and I checked and it's a 19th
century kind of thing so I feel pretty
safe doing this thing and it just felt
like a really fun object to mimic around
the lift Oh
basically these are just going to be the
two big wheels around the lift Hill
which supposedly spin around as you hook
onto the lifts which I can't do because
in game limitations obviously but that's
the sort of fantasy idea behind it and
so these would in real life be the
wheels that spin the cable of the cable
cars they also kind of resemble the
wheels that you see in other gondolas
whether you like the station mechanisms
are all exposed which I also find really
cool to look at and it's really that
kind of atmosphere that I try to get at
with these wheels at the bottom of the
little here and these are basically
going to be the machinery that drive the
cable even though there is that little
machine underneath the beginning of the
cable and we can do this with much less
grotesque machinery today I just figured
it would be a really cool way to get
some scenery around here and I'll also
keep this more or less empty in the area
around this - like this little Valley
where the coaster dips and drops into at
later stages and where it hooks onto the
lift at the beginning is more or less
just going to be empty and sort of like
a divider between the two parts of the
ride having the station and the top of
the lift Hill has the two parts just do
not make everything too detailed and too
much of a sea of just things to look at
but make it a little bit more neat and
have some areas with not that much
detail as well just to keep it a little
easier on the eye
I guess secretly also a little easier
for myself to make but that's something
I shouldn't have said I mean quite
honestly though I also wanted to keep
this very scenery less so that from the
station's perspective you would see the
towers in the background quite clearly
and from the background perspective you
could see the station which is also
quite new rainy in the background quite
clearly as well without any sort of
distractions or things blocking the view
in the middle which is what also why I
wanted to keep all the objects and all
the scenery in this place here quite low
and close to the ground just so that you
have
detail around here makes the interesting
makes the ride a little bit more
interesting but it's not something that
completely obscures the view of anything
else in the ride and I also wanted to
get some simple foliage around here I've
gotten some comments that I should add
as little foliage as I can in this ride
in general but I do add quite a bit of
foliage just to make it look a bit
fancier but I won't go too far it's more
or less kind of the foliage that you
would probably see around like the Seven
Dwarfs Mine Train even though it's just
a little bit more than that just the
kind of foliage that you see around mine
train coasters in general as well not
too much but still keeping some greenery
in there and to not make it one big door
mess though I didn't want to go for like
a specific sort of pallets if you will
for the foliage here so you notice that
I use that little very dark every green
color ish I'm still not good with colors
a little bush just to get some darker
sort of shades of green in here and try
to avoid the really lights bushes and
the very lights flatbush in favor of the
newer more gritty colored kind of
foliage as well as the little white
flowers which I figured would fit in
quite well with that stew at least get a
bit of color but not make it too
colorful and brights and too big of a
contrast with the steampunk scenery and
actually think that little bush works
quite well as a little sort of overgrown
grassy looking foliage bit as well so
I'm actually quite happy with how that
turned out to anyway just placing some
trees for the thumbnail here and that's
basically it so I'm gonna move on to a
real time section which I've saved
alright so this is what the coaster
looks like at the moment it's still
mostly unfinished but the majority of
the main sort of hill in the middle is
already finished at least on this side
so it does give a good idea of what it's
going to look like more or less in the
end I do want to continue this sort of
general terrorists light thing which I
have on this side on this side as well
but I don't get too many details in and
much like I have over here this area is
kind of empty at the moment and I do in
a
leave this empty just to be able to
bring out the details of the parts that
I will heavily team out a little bit
more not make it too chaotic over here
and like it's too much to see or just
see Punk objects did I just see see Punk
I totally meant steampunk and I might
get like a chimney over here I'm still
not sure about that one but I still
wanna have like a little bit more
scenery around this area as well but
yeah this is basically what this part
looks like at the moment I do really
like how like the horizontal sort of
terrorists look of these objects over
here especially these like little paths
and walls that stick out kind of bring
out a little bit of a horizontal feel to
the hill itself and then you have those
vertical elements especially like the
tower is that kind of tower up higher a
little bit and I'm actually really happy
with how the wheels came out that really
drive the little or supposedly do over
here as well and they should more or
less also be the final sort of machinery
that I have run this area this is more
going to be over sort of sort of natural
making its way through canyons at the
end of the quarry kind of part without
all of the machinery and steampunky
details that the rest of the ride has
and yeah that's pretty much most of my
planning at the moment and I'm probably
also a bit closer to completion than it
really looks because so far I've already
made a bit more progress than I expected
to make in this episode and the rest is
a little bit more simple than the really
important we need stuff over here and I
think I might actually be able to at
least finish this part and move on with
this part in the next episodes and get
that all over with in like two or three
maybe episodes and a couple more parts
to get this area around this all done
but even though it doesn't really look
like it I think I'm already quite almost
finished with major parts of the
roller-coaster already so that's pretty
good this will more or less stay the way
that it is at the moment I won't really
change much about it there are a couple
of things which I like might tweak a
little bit but this should be the
general look like I really won't go into
too much detail around this valley in
general
just to have the details that I have at
the moment pop out a little bit more and
also keep most of the attention because
that is more or less the intention over
here on the central Hill over here which
really has the highest amount of detail
and the highest point of the ride as
well see how thank you guys for watching
next time I'll try to get some stuff in
in this area so I hope to see you guys
then